[Music]
don't forget to enter our amazon gift
card giveaway all you have to do is like
the video and comment
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about everything we know about the
4th episode of season 8
supportive trailers theaters and
previews episode 4 will be amazing
and will visit multiple different
locations from winterfell to dragonstone
and king's landing
it'll be a buildup episode for the last
war the battle for the armed throne that
comes in episode 5.
the episode will open up at winterfell
where we'll see the ruins of the
aftermath of the battle of bannerfeld
everyone is tired but before they can
rest for a while before departing for
general snow they need to burn the dead
and pay their respects yeah that's right
the next location for jon and dan in
their forces
is dragonstone one of the teasers
provided this shot of dany standing in
front of a fireplace
where her back turned to jon and details
on that fireplace confirmed they are a
dragonstone
i've already talked too much about it in
my previous videos but in case you
missed it here's how we know his
dragonstone
take a look at all the details on the
shot from the fireplace itself to its
props
the stone curves and the metalwork it's
the same thing we already saw a giant
stone
the reason they are going to dragonstone
rather than straight to king's landing
to fight cersei
is probably because dany left some of
our forces there to defend dragonstone
but also because dragonstone will be the
place where they'll forge a new plan of
defeating cersei
anyways as i said before they sail to
dragonstone they will have quite a few
scenes in winterfell
they will firstly burn their dead and
pay respects to those many that were
lost
including theon gradually and anger
mormont bearing dondarrion ed cono and
melisandre
here we see the mass funeral pyres with
the surviving characters in attendance
from left to right the torchbearers are
thormun johnson zarya griform danny and
sam
also present are john royce that was
sievert brain ghost varys miss sandy
brienne tyrion and jaime
out of everyone dany loves the most from
advisors and generals jorah and kono
to most of her armies the dothraki and
the unsolid
i would be surprised if after the battle
of nfl she has more than a hundreds of
solid and even fewer dothraki left
however there's a possibility that not
all of the threaki died in the battle of
nfl
as the track erects fire slowly died in
the dark fear left to assume all of them
died
but that might not be the case during
the episode we saw multiple times how
winter extinguishes fire
so maybe it extinguished fire on the
track erects as well and not all of them
died
but instead ran away into darkness the
reason behind this possibility is that
we never saw them die
we saw the lights go off but that's it
they could have clashed a bit
then split off and retreated somewhere
else one big evidence for this
is ghost ghost disappeared and did not
return just like most of the tracking
so you would assume he died but in
trailer for next episode he is back
alive and not injured
maybe just maybe there's more dothraki
to survive the battle of winterfell
anyways there's not much time left to
mourn their death
then it's quick to start her new
campaign for the armed throne starting
with rallying her battered followers to
winnefeld
we have won the great war she says now
will win the last one
then he raises her cup as her followers
rejoice
there's a ton of cheering for dany it
looks like she's won the nords respect
the north was tough to accept a new
ruler but then he earned it
and not only with her dragons but with
her herself fighting on the ground with
a sword
to defend the north soon after they will
ride out of winterfell
and leave for white harbor to their
ships and then travel to dragonstone
sansa will probably not be coming with
them and neither velarya stark
sansa will likely stay at winterfell
batara will go for king's landing
even though jon daniel cruz ultimate
destination is go to king's landing and
fight cersei
they will firstly take some time to
rally the forces and forge a plane at
dragonstone
arie will go on her own mission to shut
the green eyes
cersei's eyes and she will be
accompanied by the hound
this was confirmed by some official
thesis mazie williams said this for
arya's story for season 8.
there's this split vitaria between
trying to be who she wants to be getting
back to back to death navitay and in a
sense with her family
and her unfinished business i was
correct when i predicted that what this
means is that arya will stick with her
family
and fight for manor fell against the
night king in episode 3 which she did
but when she realizes that cersei is the
final threat and her family will not be
safe as long as cersei lives
she'll have to say a temporary goodbye
to her family and go on to complete her
infamous list
ari will go on her own mission and she
will likely be accompanied by the hound
there's a high possibility that tary
will travel to king's landing to put an
end to cersei
who let me remind you he has green eyes
or at least a try
rory mckenna who plays the hound also
hinted at this when he gave us a hint at
a confrontation between the count and
the mountain by saying
there will be a chance of screaming up
to his brother and facing those demons
before they depart for king's landing
she will have one last moment with
gendry
all of our favorite characters share the
same goal defeat and kill cersei
lannister
some will firstly go to dragonstone and
wait to rally all the forces before
marching into the last war
while others will try to sneak up into
the red keep and and cersei's reign this
way
killing the night king is not the end of
game of thrones as many thought it would
be
and instead the final battle will be
with cersei even though i'm surprised
the night king was defeated this early
i'm not surprised cersei is the final
enemy because george armor revealed way
back in 2015 that it would be her
and not the night king but the night
king dead danny's next target is cersei
lannister
there's no talking to her she's the
biggest threat to stability
even at the end of season 7 there seems
to be a coming together of everyone but
her
an actor who plays fairy's said and
daddy that varys is frightened for her
he's aware of how dangerous she is and
how bad she is
he also revealed that we could see varys
somehow a dany and her allies using his
former spy net for king king's landing
the same ones not working for qyburn
hill said for a while varys was in
marine
so it wasn't as strong a connection but
supposedly he still did have them yeah
maybe the little birds would turn on
qyburn or maybe qyburn has been working
for varys so
long as my very popular theory suggests
we'll see
what we know is that varys will continue
serving targaryens
and he will most likely make them a new
allegiance they will provide them
thousands of more soldiers
and it's going to be nonetheless than
with cersei's own alliance and mercenary
organization
the golden company conleth hill an actor
who plays varys tees that varys will be
as effective as always in season 8.
what it means in for shadows is versus
turning the golem company against her
senior
persuading them to fight for the last
regular son aegon targaryen
since after all black or red a dragon is
still a dragon
we have been listening over and over
again how the going company have never
broken a contract
that them breaking it and supporting
targaryens seems like such an obvious
twist of the final season
additionally the golden company have
already broken a contract in the books
and you guessed who was the reason a
targaryen at this point cersei received
news of the living defeating the dead of
winterfell
and she's fully aware that the living
led by jon and danny will come for her
now
cersei is prepared as she watches her
troops assembling king's landing
i can bet you she is preparing the
wildfire below king's landing
uranus by cersei's side and a bit later
we see him kneel before a smiling cersei
what i think happens here is cersei
tells jiren she is pregnant and it's his
child
so your nails and as for her handy
marriage
i believe cersei is pregnant for real
and she'll tell yeon he is the father
that's why she slept with him the season
7 official scripts not only proved that
her pregnancy is real
but she was also supposed to have a
miscarriage in season 7 finale which was
cut at the last moment
it's going to be interesting to see how
all this plays out
we also have a shot of cersei
accompanied by the mountain urine and
qyburn standing in wait
what are they looking at or who are they
waiting for
leaked photos might answer that question
it could be jon snow coming on rhaegal
to parliament cersei
john snow will return to king's landing
in episode 4.
for the first time in the history of the
series starkid herrington was filmed
shooting something in jubronic meaning
that johnny is headed back to his laning
at some point in season 8
and since director of episode 4 was seen
on set
we can say for a fact that this will
take place in episode 4.
in this photo kit harrington is the
dubrovnik minster tower
which is part of the city wolves cersei
and jon snow meet one on one in king's
landing
well not exactly one on one as cersei
has the mountain and queens guard around
i think jon is coming to parliament
cersei and try to prevent another war
that is going to make many more
casualties i think john wilkes rhaegal
who by the base to ride the battle of
nfl and has his being thorn
and john will basically show her they
still have dragons and offer her a
peaceful deal
no war no revenge she just has to leave
king's landing with her armies
and go to casterly rock leaving the iron
throne for dany
cersei will of course chose violence and
more and that's how this parliament
the only option left for jon and danny
this point is to rip out cersei
root and stem or at least they will try
in episode 5.
as i said in the beginning the episode
is a buildup episode for the last war
the battle for the armed town that comes
in episode 5.
it's this episode that will give us an
answer on who sits on the arm throne at
the end
in conclusion what we know about episode
four of the final season is
it will open up at winterfell where
we'll see the aftermath of the great war
with the survivors burning their dead
there will be a huge meeting at minerval
where danny will announce they're going
into their last war the one against
cersei
they will soon after depart for white
harbor the main seaport of the north
and shell back to dragonstone where they
will rally their forces
and forge plan for attack on king's
landing sansa and ireland stark will not
go with them
sansa will most likely stay at
winterfell while official tease is
confirmed ari will depart from her
family
upon realizing the starks will never be
safe as long as cersei lives
cersei is the green eye zarya needs to
shut forever and she will go on that
mission with the hound who also has to
face his brother who happens to be
cersei's personal guard
john will meet cersei to try and
convince her to leave king's landing
leave the army to run for dany so they
all could live but cersei will choose
violence
as she has no intention of giving away
her crown especially now that her armies
are stronger
and she has new scorpions to deal with
dragons episode 4 is going to be a great
episode but it's episode 5 and the
things will actually go down
episode 5 is just like episode 3
directed by miguel sapochnick
and is confirmed to be the last and the
final battle of game of thrones
the last war at the end of episode 5
we'll know who won the game of thrones
ok guys there will be everything we know
about the season 8 episode 4
supportivity supportivito trailers
teasers previous and a few spoilers
how do you like the fourth episode of
the final season and what do you think
will also take place
please make sure to let me know in the
comment section down below
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one
peace